so our story started several years ago
my wife and I got a complaint letter in
the mail from an anonymous neighbor all
right I'll never forget the way my wife
transformed before my eyes from this
graceful peaceful sweet woman into just
an angry mother grizzly bear whose Cubs
needed to be protected it was intense so
here's what happened this is our family
this is my wife and I and our five
awesome kids we're pretty loud we're
pretty rambunctious we're us you'll
notice so that two of our children look
a little different than Mary and I and
that's because they came to us through
adoption our neighbor though saw two
different looking children playing
outside of our house every day and came
to the conclusion that we must have been
running an illegal daycare out of our
home we were really angry to have our
children stereotyped like that but I
know that's a relatively minor example
of racial profiling but isn't sometimes
what we all tend to do with people who
think differently or believe differently
or maybe even vote differently instead
of engaging as true neighbors we keep
our distance and our actions towards
those are guided by who we think sees
the world as we do or who we think
doesn't see what my neighbors suffered
from is a condition called agonism and
sometimes we all suffer from the same
condition it's not a medical condition
but it is contagious so let's talk a
little bit about what agonism is my
favorite definition of agonism is taking
a warlike stance in contexts that are
not literally war agonism comes from the
same Greek root word a gone from which
we get agony how very appropriate
we all tend to show symptoms of agonism
when we hold on to two deeply held
beliefs first identified by author Rick
Warren the first one is that if we love
someone we must agree with all they do
or belief and the second is the inverse
that if we disagree with someone it must
mean that we fear or we hate them
not sure we really recognize the agony
this way of thinking brings to us when
our relationships die because we think
we have to agree or disagree no matter
what think about the conversations we've
had around brexit or Hong Kong maybe
Israeli settlements or perhaps
impeachment I bet we could all think of
at least one personal relationship
that's been strained or maybe even ended
because of these topics are tragically
over a topic much more trivial than
those the cure for agonism is not out of
reach the question is how so - suggests
two strategies that my experience has
taught me to start with first cultivate
common ground which means focusing on
what we share I want you to know I'm
using my words very very deliberately I
cultivate I mean we have to
intentionally work to find common ground
with someone just like a farmer works to
cultivate the soil and common ground is
a common term so let me at least explain
what I don't mean which is I don't mean
by common ground that we were exact or
that we totally agree in a proof all I
mean is that we find one unifying thing
that we can have in relationship in
common with another person you know
sometimes that one thing is hard to find
so I'd like to share a personal story
but before I do let me tell you a little
bit more about myself
I'm Caucasian success cisgender male
middle class evangelical Christian and I
know as soon as some of those words came
out of my mouth some of you had some
perceptions about me
and it's okay I know that not all those
perceptions are positive but for those
who share my faith know that I'm about
to cut across the grain and you may tune
me out as well so as we go if you're
having a hard time hearing me I just
gently ask that you reflect and see if
you're buying into agonism if you're
rejecting me simply because you think
you see the world differently than I do
because isn't that what we're here
talking about alright ready so I've been
thinking a lot about how to find common
ground in the area of gender fluidity as
an evangelical Christian for Christians
like me we believe that God created us
man and woman so what do I do if I throw
up my hands and say I can't have a
relationship with anybody who's
transgender or LGBTQIA
know I would be giving in to agonism so
I started looking at the foundational
aspects of my faith the first of which
is that of the 3 billion genes that make
us human and by the way we share 99.9%
of those genes that I believe those
three billion genes are the result of an
intelligent designer and that
immediately gives me common ground with
anybody what it also gives me is the
belief that each and every one of us
have been given the right to life by
that same intelligent designer dug
deeper though I found that my faith
didn't teach me to start relationships
by arguing with somebody until they
believed what I believed or I convinced
them no it taught me to start
relationships by loving them as a
co-equal member of the human race
honestly though some who share my faith
draw a line and refused to address
somebody by their preferred gender
pronoun but isn't that believing the lie
that in order for me to honor you I have
to give up what I believe
come back in time with me let's say it's
20 years ago and Muhammad Ali comes to
your doorstep and you open the door
would you address him as Muhammad Ali or
his former name of Cassius Clay I'm
guessing that most of you would say
Muhammad Ali and I'm also guessing that
most of you wouldn't think we'd have to
immediately convert to Islam just by
using his name to honor him would cost
me would cost any of us absolutely
nothing and it would give us the common
ground to have a relationship and it's
the relationship that cures agonism not
giving up what we believe so for me to
honor my faith it means rejecting these
rigid symptoms of agonism meaning I can
and I will love you I can and I will
accept you and I don't have to buy into
the lie that if I do these things I have
to give up what I believe or choose to
fear and hate you because I'm focusing
on what we have in common when you can
find even the smallest bit of common
ground with somebody it allows you to
understand just a beautiful wonder and
complexity and majesty of the other
person our second strategy gives us room
to breathe the pause to calm down to
have the kind of relationships that cure
agonism and how to keep those
relationships alive our second strategy
is to exchange extravagant grace once
again I'm not mincing words by grace I
don't mean we should all go sign up for
a ballet that would be weird
what I mean is not canceling everything
over one mistake even if that mistake
personally offended you maybe even
deeply
perhaps Holocaust survivor Corrie ten
Boom put it best when she said to
forgive is to set a prisoner free only
to realize that prisoner was me my faith
teaches me that we humans will never be
perfect myself very much included so we
need the grace of a savior who for me is
Jesus and while I define grace in the
context of my faith I know there's a lot
of other people who have defined it
differently and in different ways one of
my favorites is radio broadcaster Oswald
Huffman who said grace is the love that
loves the unlovely and the unlovable I
just love that picture of grace because
I know I am and maybe a lot of you can
think of a time when we're just pretty
dadgum unlovable so it would be the
height of hypocrisy dare I say repulsive
to my faith for me to accept the
unconditional unqualified grace and love
from God and then turn around and put
one precondition on the love I give you
what in the world would I be saying
and by extravagant I mean over-the-top
not just checking a box you can all
remember when we were kids and our
parents forced us to apologize to
somebody and we walked up to them and
said I'm sorry we just got it over with
right that's not what we're talking
about we're talking about is not having
to give someone grace but choosing to
and wanting to that's how we exchanged
extravagant grace listen I know this can
sound really really theoretical so I'd
like to tell you about a hero of mine a
hero of grace it's 2014 in Iran and the
mother of a murdered son is in a public
square the man who murdered her son is
also in that Square by a gallows on a
chair of some kind a noose around his
neck and a blindfold over his eyes
Samara Allen Ahad had been given the
sole right under the laws of her country
to either pardon this man or initiate
his execution
put another way she could pardon him or
literally push that chair out from
underneath his feet I could I just can't
picture the agony going through both
Samara and this man at the time Samara
with her choice to make and this man in
the account that I read was just weeping
just begging for forgiveness and Samara
had a choice and she chosen that moment
to walk up to this man and to slap him
right across the face and that signaled
her pardon it gets better
right afterwards somebody asked her what
do you what do you they interviewed her
and she was quoted as saying I felt as
if rage vanished from within my heart
and the blood in my veins began to flow
again and that incredible and what a
picture
of Christ what a hero of grace and
there's a lesson in there for all of us
that as theologian John Piper said grace
is power not just pardon and if you
think about it grace is the gift we give
someone else in a relationship that says
our relationship is way more important
than the things that separate us and if
you really think about it some more we
all have the power to execute in our
relationships or to pardon we never did
find out the identity of our anonymous
neighbor but if we did I hope we simply
say can we have coffee and maybe there's
somebody you need to have coffee with
and find your common ground with them or
maybe there's somebody you're in a
relationship with and you need to
exchange extravagant grace maybe go
first these two strategies have taught
me how to exchange extravagant grace in
my relationships and to enjoy the
beautiful design of my neighbor's I want
to continue to choose relationships over
agonism will you choose to join me thank
you
[Applause]
[Music]